here we go again it's time to break some
hearts and lose a few more limbs i guess
like where do we even go after the
international assassins are it was just
literally freaking mental like i lost i
was just creaming with excitement
wanting more and more to the point i
went out and actually managed to find
the next physical arc in paperback form
then binged it in bed as soon as i got
home like stupidly of me i said in the
last video that i thought the previous
arc was my favorite after i read it and
i didn't know how it was possibly going
to be outclassed but now i'm just left
in complete awe at the utter beauty of
the writing that has been handed to us
on a platter of just orgasmic panels i
never expected anything like this the
twists and turns this arc gives us truly
plays on our minds to the point i
actually felt like i was going insane
not wanting the supposed outcome to
actually come true as if it did it would
surely be the worst possible outcome in
the world for our boy denji so yes this
here is the short and second to last but
no less heartbreaking gun devil arc from
tatsuki fujimotos chainsaw man but
quickly just before we do move forward
if you want more story based content
just like what i've been doing with
chainsaw man but for other series then
make sure you hit that subscribe button
and tell me what other shows you want me
to cover down in the comment section
below plus join the discord i obviously
hardly ever mention it but when
something insane goes down like when i'm
reading a manga or something i literally
lose it and go into the general chat
there so be sure to join there if you
want to chat or just give me other ideas
for manga to actually read in the future
so previously on the life of our half
chainsaw half human hybrid denji along
with everyone else from his team and the
opposing enemies were sent to hell and
treated like toys by one of the primal
fears themselves the darkness devil
luckily mommy makima [__] my life i'm
never i'm never saying that again save
the day and manage to manipulate the
situation enough to get everyone back
however then you still had to clutch up
and slay santa claus after being
returned to the mortal realm using the
power of light and tv infomercials dingy
was able to overcome mrs claus and a new
dull darkness type ability which
honestly was just cracked like i'm in
the same boat as santa here actually
confused on how dingy managed to really
come out on top of that situation but
obviously we move on now so after the
battle now and back at home dingy awakes
with power lying across his chest he's
then greeted by aki who is making
breakfast dingy comments on powers
screaming throughout the night before
mentioning arki's arm aki informs him
that he was lucky as angel had lost both
of his arms by the way if you didn't
notice the arms that the darkness devil
cuts off spells out mahima whilst
obviously sadly beam and the violence
theme both died and kabini actually
resigned this time randomly then powell
begins screaming dingy tries restraining
her as she attempts to claw into her own
mouth out of fear of the darkness devil
hiding inside of it clutching dingy she
now begins to cry with just pure fear of
the darkness devil but hey at least
power is still a life out of everyone so
far like honestly i was heartbroken when
i saw beam and all the other guys get
turned into darkness sushi but at least
power and aki are still alive at the
moment anyway a short while later as
they all eat breakfast and power
struggles to keep her food down aki
comments on how mahima is still deciding
to continue her trip in a flashback
mahima and dingy share a meal while
discussing the aftermath of the conflict
part way through the conversation mahima
invites dingy on a trip with her to
which she reacted with intense
excitement yet he suddenly stopped when
he remembered power and the state she is
currently in back in the present aki
asks why he didn't ultimately choose to
go but denji simply responds that he
isn't even certain throughout the day
power interrupts denji at awkward
moments constantly asking him to check
for the darkness devil hiding in various
locations this work pays off though for
our boy as he gets in there and power
actually asks him to take a bath with
her but of course only for protection
from the darkness devil in random
japanese fashion i guess the two shower
and then hop into a bath afterwards like
my mum would actually kill me if i did
that [__] here now in the bath dingy is
surprised that despite the intimacy of
their act it doesn't feel weird nearing
beard now aki suggests sleeping in
shifts in order to look after power that
night power wakes dingy quietly begging
him to not hate her for making him miss
his trip and in return she offers to let
him drink her blood as repayment though
dingy is initially uninterested power
begins to shout and cry resulting in him
giving in as he begins to drink the
blood from her neck and are kind of like
sexual man
he thinks of pochisa and what makima had
told him yet now despite having a close
intimate relationship with power none of
the actions they do feel romantic at all
concluding that there are some things
that one is better off not knowing or
understanding then she thinks back to
the door and his nightmares resolving to
keep it closed just please open the door
man i want to see what's behind it
surely it's just pachita's house akin
films dingy and power of his plans to
visit hokkaido denji and power both
protest about being left behind since
their previous trip was cancelled aki
eventually gives in and the trio leave
meowi with kashibe the dedicated katari
after one literally terrible journey for
aki the three are seen moving on foot
towards the grave dingy and power throw
snowballs at aki which is obviously
super reminiscent for him if you think
about the dude's little bro and how him
and dingy have like kind of over time
developed to be almost brothers in a way
since they first met after arriving at
his family grave arki begins to pray
noting denji and powell's disappearance
he then sees them eating rotten
offerings left on the graves suddenly
power vomits up the food before
screaming that it was a plot by the
darkness devil
later at an inn while they eat dinner
powell complains about the amount of
vegetables throwing them to the others
before realising that there is little
food left for herself instead she takes
dingy's arm and bites into it drinking
his blood and causing another argument
that night dingy awakes to see aki
sitting looking out of the window at the
snow as he joins him aki comments that
he visits the grave each year and is
usually miserable but funnily enough the
two of them managed to keep him
distracted the entire time
back in tokyo now kishibe returns meowi
to aki kishibe then comments on the
difficulties of controlling dingy in
power but aki responds that the pair
have actually matured a lot he then asks
kashibo where the division 4 could be
removed from the gun devil hunt which
surprises kishibe he then tries to
remind him of the safety precautions
being taken as well as the fact that the
mission will be classified meaning aki
may never hear of its outcome unless he
is directly involved baraki still agrees
which causes a confused kishibe to ask
why he changed his mind and aki thinks
back to seeing denji and powers
unconscious and injured bodies in hell
before responding i got cold feet
that evening ahi returns home to see
denji and power preparing dinner for him
noting a strange purple wrote within it
dingy comments that power likely added
some unknown secret ingredients as they
too boast on their meal aki takes a bite
before instantly vomiting power happily
calls the dish a catastrophe as dingy
comments on the fact that all three of
them now have vomited from it now lying
on the beard together aki comments on
power's calmness and the lack of
screaming power considers this before
responding that she may have defeated
the darkness devil in hell to which
dingy casually agrees as they wash the
dishes they suddenly receive a phone
call summoning them to the bureau
messing with makima she informs the
group that while she has taken aki and
the rest of division iv of the gun devil
mission denji and power are still
required to go she asks aki to leave if
he does not intend to join them denji
agrees to the mission followed by power
who wishes to continue working nice and
close with denji troubled aki asks to
rejoin the mission to which makima
swiftly agrees honestly i think mikey
was kind of playing archie right now i
don't know what's going on here having
already begun the operation makima then
details the current status of the gun
devil explaining that it had already
been defeated and confined denji and aki
respond with utter shock as makima
explains it was found dead shortly after
its initial attack before being split
into various fragments aki asks about
the guns used previously against the
devil hunters only for makima to reveal
that they were created by man she
elaborates explaining that though there
is an official global ban on firearms
each government secretly manufactures
and circulates guns on their black
markets in doing so the remaining
fragments of the gun devil are given
more power hearing this aki realizes
that in order to destroy the gun devil
the bureau will need to go against the
wishes of every global superpower mahima
calmly agrees calling the plan a kind of
war
outside dingy and power questioned aki's
despondence still believing the mission
to be about simply killing the gun devil
ahi explains that even after they kill
the gun devil their body would merely be
collected by the japanese government
continuing the cycle of the global
hostilities whilst also meaning the gun
devil is immortal denji expresses
confusion believing that the gun devil
must be mortal or else makima would not
have promised him a wish in return for
killing it suddenly aki is given a
vision of the future by the future devil
reacting with sudden and intense fear
that night alone aki summons the future
devil asking about the vision the future
devil explains that it is a mere and
unavoidable future one in which archi
and power are slaughtered by dingy
followed by the arrival of the devils
that devils fear most
so yeah here we go guys let's get in
that part of the story where it's gonna
get real well now i think sometime in
the next few days aki visits angel and
explains his future vision to him angel
asks why he is being informed given that
the vision is supposedly unavoidable aki
explains that with the loss of both of
his arms there is a possibility the
bureau will put angel down
as such hen kishibe wrote a letter of
recommendation and your questions aki's
devil-hating reputation
baaki suddenly informs him of their plan
to hunt the gun devil and that they may
never see one another again angel stops
him explaining that the humans whose
lifespan he's absorbed often haunt his
nightmares and offers to do whatever he
can to prevent ahi's death so that the
same doesn't happen with him he then
suggests that they both go and ask
makima for advice
as they walk angels suggest he run away
and leave his life with the bureau
behind in order to prevent his own death
but aki refuses citing denji power and
mahima as reasons to stay
surprised by his mentioning of mahima
angel comments on aki's feelings for her
and as the pair spot makima aki also
quietly begins to wonder why exactly he
actually likes her aki asks why she's
there to which she responds that she was
simply waiting aki then explains his
vision and desire to keep power and
denji safe blaming himself for his
brother's death he asks the same be
prevented with them and promises to make
any contract with any devil to do so
hearing this makima looks him in the eye
before asking him to make a contract
with her
aki reacts with shock as makima repeats
herself now commanding him to accept the
contract as the angel devil looks on he
slowly begins to remember the beach as
the location where he was first found by
mahima he gradually remembers a
community of people who took him in
before focusing on a young woman from
his previous memory remembering her as
the one i loved and the one who loved me
then he remembers mahima arriving on the
beach and asking to see his powers
though he refused she demanded ordering
him to use them hours later he then
reawoke having absorbed the lives of
everyone in the village damn honestly
this one hurt like it's real super sad
to realize the cool introduction angel
had actually
had an extremely sad beginning like he
murked an entire village but that
village was his family and he was merely
controlled by makima snapping back to
the present angel reacts with horror as
he sees aki now accepting mahima's
contract he begins to yell out to makima
and as she turns to look at him she
comments on how he must have just
regained his memories instantly using 10
years of life force to create a dope ass
blade the angel devil lunges at makima
in an attempt to cut her head off
however just before the blade nears her
throat she merely says the word down and
the angel devil crumples to the floor
impressed that he had managed to break
free of her power making me kneels next
to him ordering the devil to give his
all to her to which he agrees then
apologizing to the two of them makima
explains that she had no other choice
due to the massive amount of spies
within the japanese bureau the hunt for
the gun devil was always a bluff planned
to fail hiding her ulteria plan
one in which will occur the greatest
amount of damage worldwide flashing away
to the goddamn united states of america
hell yeah westerners let's go there the
president while on the phone to probably
the other members of congress states
that the time has come because of the
duty he must try to uphold when every
other nation has just accepted utter
defeat he makes a contract with the gun
devil one in which he offers one year of
the lifespan of all citizens across the
entire continent of the united states of
america in return for the death of
makima the control devil
so yeah that explains a lot back in
japan as the church bells ring and the
choir of children sing mahima incites
the gun devil telling it to come on
september 12 1997 the gun devil appears
in japan once it appears it activates a
flurry of abilities instantly fire a
bullet through the head of every male
within a thousand meters confirmed
activate second ability fire a bullet
through children's age zero through
twelve within fifteen hundred meters
confirmed literally decimating
everything within its vicinity as it
slowly reveals the true scope of the gun
devil a few seconds before the gun devil
arrived a young boy was planning to go
play soccer with his friends he heads
out of the door but one second later the
city he is in is obliterated by the gun
devil's presence as it makes its way
towards makima another second passes and
at 500 kilometers makima cites the
gandival continuing to move forward
towards her direction at ridiculous
speeds multiple examples of devastation
are shown with peaceful cities turned
into complete devastation cars flipped
and countless thousands instantly killed
by the fallout as another second passes
the gun devil activates his ability to
fire a bullet through the heart of every
living thing born on specific months
throughout the year within a one
kilometer radius
exactly four seconds after its first
appearance the gun devil stops it then
activates another ability and starts
beaming its bullets in makima's
direction
one second later makima prepares her
ability but is shot through the head
making her 29th recorded death as
expected though she immediately recovers
as her brain meta forms into a freaking
halo around her head not gonna lie this
panel here is so freaking fire man it's
so cool some of these panels recently
i've just been losing it i've been
creaming everywhere anyways one more
second later the gun devil again stops
as in front of him makima stands with
the bodies of prinz sawatari aki angel
corrose nintendo who are all shown to be
attached to her will they chain
summoning the combined power of all of
their devil contracts a sudden hole
opens up in the sky above the gun devil
as a swarm of unknown creatures descend
wielding blades flashing away from
probably what is the gun devil getting
absolutely stunted on over at their
apartment then she hears a knock on the
door and goes to answer it however as he
reaches for the handle he sees a vision
of his nightmare as pachetta's words
echo through his head telling him to not
open the door
as the pounding on the door continues
denji is interrupted by the phone
suddenly ringing on the other end mahima
who is being a freaking ho like stuff
her man i bet this was her plan all
along to kill beam and hell plus what is
going down right now it's all just so
suspect she quickly explains to dingy
that the gun devil had appeared without
warning and then failed to defeat it and
because of that it has taken over a dead
body and escaped going on to say that
it's the gun devil at the door makima
then commands denji to not think about
anything while he fights
even still despite this call both dingy
and power are skeptical believing the
person at the door knocking to be aki
coming home from the mission
yet as denji approaches the door he
can't help but seem to grow more and
more hesitant because of this he tells
power to leave with meowi from the
balcony just in case it actually is the
devil dingy still uncertain thinking
that possibly makima might even be
playing a prank opens the door sadly
revealing the reanimated corpse of aki
who is now morphed into and is
controlled by the gun devil
denji not recognizing it though
awkwardly asks whether the two must
fight now however the devil simply
raises the gun and says denji's name
which causes denji to wonder how the gun
devil even knows his name on a different
perspective we find ourselves inside of
aki's mind ahi looking at his hand finds
a snowball and realizes he must have
been having a snowball fight with denji
yet in reality each snowball thrown by
arki translates to a massively
destructive gun blast in the real world
completely leveling dingy's floor of the
building having fallen from the building
now dingy finds himself torn in half by
the blast even still he commands power
to flee as the two come to the
realization that the creature is arky
suddenly aki's gun devil leaps from the
building at breakneck speed in an
attempt to kill power yet our freaking
boy ain't letting power die yet as he
manages to transform in time to block
the attack
now in arky's fantasy power has also
joined with aki telling power that she's
on denji's team then as he begins to
fang his snowballs at the two it flashes
back to the real world to show the
complete devastation as aki sends both
power and denji flying back noticing a
pair of bystanders he turns and points
his machinery at them asking if they
also want to play with him instantly he
vaporizes them though will they smile on
his face as denzhi begins to attack and
slice into him aki only views this as
dingy playfully throwing snowballs right
back at him the battle escalates with
every blast by aki quickly leveling
massive amounts of the surrounding area
sending cars flying and murdering
countless civilians
though denji attempts to protect some
his efforts are largely fruitless as the
majority of everyone he saves later gets
hurt they continue fighting with aki's
smile growing wider and wider with each
blast dingy screams out for ahi to stop
and return back to normal yayaki's
fantasy self can't hear anything he is
saying and in aki's reality he can only
see the smile on his brother dingy's
face
seeing his smile he comments on how for
the first time he's having fun as his
parents never really paid any attention
to him but now his life actually seems
like fun as he says this denji is both
hit in the gut by the snowball and in
reality by a catastrophic shock knocking
him to the floor while lucky's fantasy
continues he asks the child dingy if
he's giving up but as he begins to stand
back up he thinks he's ready for another
round of snowball fighting in the real
world though arkey continues his
onslaught repeatedly blasting dingy
backwoods dingy attempts to defend
himself but because he is unwilling to
hurt aki he's forced to simply beg for
him to turn back this is like some next
level obi so versus kakashi type battle
right now like the crossover of
childhood to
to adult type thing i'm just loving it
like it's so
sad but good and odds just this arc is
actually fantastic man suddenly aki lets
have a massive blast sending digi flying
back through multiple buildings causing
him to lose one arm and both legs while
dingy lies crippled in the ruins of a
building slowly a crowd of onlookers
gather around him a woman approaches
pulling out a knife before suddenly
stabbing her own hand and asking him to
save them each bystander then does the
same and gives dengi blood and begs for
him to defeat the devil and save them
all with the city now in complete and
utter tatters the gun devil slowly makes
his way towards denji meanwhile during
aki's dream denji begins biffing
snowballs back with insane force though
aki is initially excited by this he
quickly notes then she is crying in his
fantasy so in order to stop this aki
admits to fate simply falling back onto
the ground and saying that he doesn't
like snowball fights anyway because they
just get your hands cold when he looks
back up he notices that denji has gone
and he is instead replaced by his
younger brother taiyo who's running back
from the house for the balls and gloves
he went to grab earlier on in this
series damn it it always hits real hard
that power right there in reality though
it is revealed that in order to stop his
onslaught then she had stabbed aki with
his chainsaws killing him as denji
returns to his human form in shock at
what had just happened the future devil
appears on a nearby roof and laughs
commenting on how aki hayakawa died in
the worst way possible
for the chainsaw boy
yeah damn man that's like truly the
worst possible death uh dingy right
there i could possibly imagine
i can't even right now it's such a crazy
ass [__] arc that was actually
amazing tatsuki fujimoto bro you gotta
chill out and leave some people some
kind of emotions after reading like i'm
gonna be suffering
emotionally for the next 20 years or
whatever now but god damn that was
actually just amazing i couldn't
couldn't believe that the first time i
read through and then having to read
through that there oh my god anyway i
hope you guys all have enjoyed the video
obviously and smash that like button if
you want more story explained content
just like this but anyway for now it's
been your professional degenerate dear
follow and well i'm gonna go and cry in
a pillow bye